in China health officials have announced
they expect to see the corona virus
outbreak intensify the virus has already
appeared in all but one of China's
provinces and in at least 11 other
countries China has said it will boost
efforts to contain the virus that means
even more transport and travel bans
canceling major public events and
shutting tourist attractions as well as
widespread health screening meanwhile
the death toll is rising at least 56
people in China have died and more than
2,000 more have been infected a whole
city in quarantine a public health
announcement is broadcast to a
near-empty Street in Wuhan but the
medical centers are overflowing and even
if residents feel well they could still
be a carrier of the new coronavirus
china's health minister told reporters
that the virus's ability to spread is
getting stronger our knowledge of the
new coronavirus is limited the origin
hasn't been found from our observation
the disease can be spread during the
incubation period the period lasts for
10 days the shortest is one day the
longest is 14 days this is very
different from SARS and that means a
seemingly healthy person carrying the
virus can infect other people before
symptoms appear there's no vaccine or a
drug to prevent the virus but medical
researchers say first tests on a
possible vaccine could start in three
months time here in Wuhan all access to
pharmacies hotels or any other public
spaces comes after a temperature check
many residents are taking these new
restrictions in stride I'm not worried
it's not bad because the Wuhan city
government has treated us very humanely
that is to say all aspects of the
defense measures have been very
satisfactory I think know what
Home Instead doors and just you know
wait for it to pass but the doctors and
daily contact with sick patients can't
wait for it to pass dressing for battle
against the virus
the city says there's a shortage of
masks and protective goggles and blue
hand and Chinese state TV shows medical
supplies and army medics arriving in the
city from other regions to help the
stretched health services there it's the
middle of the festival of the new year a
celebration that has been drastically
scaled back this year and let's get the
latest now from our correspondent in
Beijing fab unit Kretchmer who's been
following this fabián the health
minister of China held a rare Sunday
press conference What did he say yeah he
basically reminded the press how severe
the threat is and there have been a lot
of a lot of steps have been taken um one
is by the province of the Guangdong
that's in South China and they
introduced a new regulation that
requires every citizen to wear a face
mask and if you don't wear a face mask
in public you're not allowed to enter
any kind of facilities including
restaurants also AM China banned its
trade with wild animals we know that um
we know that in Wuhan the the virus was
supposedly originating from sorry it's
supposed the originating from oh and
from an market where also exotic animals
were sold such as snakes and also
crocodiles and bets so that's also a big
step and maybe the most intense steps
were taken in Wuhan starting from today
every kind of traffic individual car
traffic is also bent can you tell us a
little bit more about these lock downs
there's several cities in lockdown what
does that mean for the Chinese people
and for foreigners who happen to be are
they stuck in China yeah for the
foreigners who are living in Wuhan I
think they get preferential treatment
for example the French authorities and
also the Russian authorities they are
negotiating and the evacuation of
they are citizens and also the US
consulate of Wuhan they already
announced that they will evacuate their
staff on Tuesday for the Chinese of
course it's more severe because they
cannot leave the city as it's a it's
sealed off and you can see that people
are stopped piling on food they're also
stockpiling on medical supplies and for
more on this I'm joined now by a
Christian linnemeier a spokesperson at
the World Health Organization China's
Health Ministry says the deadly new
virus his ability to spread it is
growing how much do we need to be
concerned it's a novel coronavirus which
means it's a new virus where we don't
have any treatment measures yet other
than the clinical treatments of you know
fighting the fever or the cloth we don't
obviously have any vaccine because it's
a new virus so it's something which we
knew would at some stage happen in the
world but it's definitely something
which is spreading and will get worse
before it gets better
we've seen travelers leaving China and
coming to other countries around the
world quite a lot by now and taking this
virus with them what we haven't seen and
that is very good news that in those
countries we haven't seen any further
transmission and that's a sign to look
out for the w-h-o is expected to
announce whether this new corona virus
will be designated what it calls a
public health emergency of international
concern
what is its current status it is
definitely an emergency in China there's
no doubt about that there's no other
official status this description of a
public health emergency of an
international concern has certain
criteria and they're quite technical
criteria it is not linked to the amount
of cases and that's very important so
we're not looking at cases or deaths
it's linked to the fact that it's a new
virus it's linked to the fact that it's
internationally spreading and it's
linked to the fact that it's human to
human transmission is ongoing in other
countries that's why the fact that this
hasn't been spreading yet further in
other countries is a very signal
in fact in in China as far as we know
all cases have yet been linked to Wuhan
directly and all human-to-human
transmission have been within closed
families or enclosed circumstances so
that's what we know right now but we're
constantly monitoring the experts of the
Emergency Committee also constantly
being up to date on what's going on they
will reconvene shortly that is something
we can safely assume and our country's
doing everything they can and should do
to stop the spread of the virus are
there any weak links in the chain here
this is now certainly a test for
international health systems of all
countries around the globe it's very
good so far that we have been seeing
travelers coming home and we see a virus
detected to us that means what it means
that it has been detected as silly as
this may sound and that is definitely
good news and these people have been
either put in isolation they have been
immediately put under treatment their
family members friends the contacts have
been reached out to and checked
medically and monitored so these are all
very good news and that's exactly what
people can do they can do exit tests our
entry tests from flights coming from
various areas people themselves should
look out for symptoms of cough or fever
of sneeze now this is of course a very
tricky scenario because it's a flu-like
virus and we have winter season still in
Europe so that means everybody can
develop a sneeze or cough or cold so
that's something which can be confused
and again it's important to know the
most the farthest way you can go for
your own protection it's the same way
you would protect yourself against the
common flu or the common cold or the flu
that means don't sneeze into the open
don't cough into the open sneeze into
your elbow or into a tissue and discard
the tissue afterwards and if you get if
you get infected your or if you touch
with somebody then wipe your hands
afterwards sanitize and maybe don't get
too close to somebody as you wouldn't if
that person is infected with anything
else all right take the usual steps as
one dozen winter Christian linnemeier
reg WH o thanks so much